you're looking young now man have you
been using like a
do you use a toner or anything like that
like a facial toner
no no not at all not at all
you know when i was young we used to uh
we used to my dad would take us over to
the funeral parlor
and um and
you know we would do like uh
you know and it was sad and everything
but on top of that we would do a have a
candy or something try to hide a candy
in the coffin of whoever was
you know being buried or being
you know deceased whoever was deceased
or being buried if
and a lot of back then i mean something
sometimes probably three or four percent
of the people you don't know if they
were fully dead or not
you know you kind of trusted people's
family back then they said hey they're
dead you know come on over and
you know we're gonna box them up for god
you know kind of deal but
um and we would try to sneak a candy in
the end of the casket
you know try to slip a gum drop in there
or slip a
gobstopper in there
because i guess the way we envisioned it
is you you would see you would think
you know then later on you know a week
later you'd be
just by yourself relaxing or
you know spending time with an animal or
something just
you know we're looking around or just
doing anything
and you would think oh that god got this
person
and then he found the candy in there
like a like a little treat
you know like a snack or something like
that you know
i think we used to envision god kind of
opening up the coffin and getting that
little snack being like oh yeah here's
one of my soldiers but also
you know here's half a handful of good
and plenty
that somebody snuck in there
um just different times you know
uh but i know you're a man of the cloth
riley now you ever do any time capsuling
any dead body time capsule or anything
like that for god you guys do any
stuff like that um not that i think uh
not that i can think of no
can't say you ever sinned like you guys
do a time capsule for
christ or anything like that through
church you guys do a
you know send a rocket up to god or
anything was there any fun stuff like
that you did as
children um not not for uh religious
purposes but i mean i've done time
capsules i've done
rockets um my dad's a rocket engineer
oh dang yeah yeah um
have you ever done it forgot you guys
ever built something for the lord and
just jacked that thing up into the sky
no i can't say i have not for the lord
i've just done it for fun
damn damn you living man
you're living big riley mal yeah man
it's the big time
let's get into it
[Music]
outdoors
now we're cooking with gas on
[Music]
outdoors
this is north mississippi all-stars
if you've got money
[Music]
and that right there that's north
mississippi all-stars
and they're banned they got a band they
are a band actually
and that's off their album up and
rolling
and that's a hit right there that's
called drunk outdoors
and you can catch the link in the uh
information
for those fellows right there
and man i'll admit it i'll be the first
to admit it
that winter you could just feel winter
you could just feel it we could just
feel winter you know a little rain came
through here earlier we're out here in
the central east out here and a little
rain
passed through nothing much just god
just drooling on top just nothing
nothing crazy you know just the lord
just drooling on us a little nothing
heavy
and and right after i said dang
something's happening
and that's winter man you could i mean
you could if you really if you put your
ear up to the ground you could hear
you know you could hear winter just
slipping summer that ghb
just putting a little dr drug in
summer's drink man
and then zipping up that body bag on
summer
because it's just that time
it's like no matter what we want to do
you want to do this you want to do
kickball
volleyball beach ball
hell if you just want to throw a damn
pool ball at somebody
you know you want to throw a damn you
know stripe seven or
whatever it is you want to hum that
bastard down the street
hit your friend curtis in a leg over
there off east st
mary street and ruin his life
even though y'all were just kids and it
was an accident whatever you want to do
it doesn't matter because mother
nature's making her choices she's
dealing her cards
and she's putting things into play man
and right now she's
just slipping that winter into you
and just really baiting you with that
winter
and you can hear it man you put your ear
up to the ground you can hear
summer just got gh beat out
and it's a wrap over there
good to have you guys here man thanks
for being with us today and that is uh
the north mississippi all-stars
again that is drunk outdoors
and they included us in that song and
some of the chorus there and
um and man we had a lot of drunk
outdoors people
uh i was in
cedar rapids iowa probably 48 hours ago
and shout out to the fella some fell out
there brought me a
half pint of fresh squid ink
you could still still the jar was still
a little wet on the outside
and shout out to that guy and the other
guy some fella brought me a um
this special rock kind of like a rock
you heat it up in the microwave or
something
and it's got you know keeps the devil
off your back and keeps uh helps you
with the
pulmonary blood flow so i appreciate
that i want to say thank you to both of
that fellow the jeweler and the other
guy
the oceanographer whatever the
underwater writer
whatever the guy with the damn inc
and they gave me hell man bring you
bring a fresh thing of squid ink back
through uh tsa they don't know how to
handle it
they don't know if you're you know just
a big fan of the perfect storm or they
don't know if
i i mean they just don't they didn't
know what to do
you know they really really didn't know
what to do over there but i told them
just honestly i said hey
this is a gift okay i'm not the kind of
i'm not the kind of fellow that runs
around with fresh squid ink
so riley mouse here what'd you get into
this weekend raleigh
uh just a few of music videos
okay a lot of fun okay um yesterday we
just did
six songs in five hours i'm at a studio
down in la verne tennessee
okay and now you guys are like when you
get out there do you bring your own
lunch with you or you eat lunch on site
or how do you usually
handle meal time i just ate before and
then i had down there
and you've mentioned you'll forget to
eat when you work
yep all the time um luckily this time i
didn't i
ate before i left i left i did the shoot
and then we all went afterwards
okay a little team outing huh oh yeah
okay
and now uh what's your bedtime usually
what time you usually nod off in the
evening
oh man two three in the morning oh wow
yeah oh wow what's the cause of that is
there any
is there something you're staying up you
waiting for something or you
what happened yeah so i'm either editing
or i go to the gym at like two in the
morning um
because that's like the prime time of
nobody's there okay
really nice especially during cofid um
but yeah that's the main reason the gym
and do you get nervous do you have body
nerves or something do you give
what is that what would you not want
people singing you no at that hour i
mean
you get nervous about your body no it's
just the smaller gym so there's not as
much
um equipment and so you would have to
wait for someone
oh yeah and so sometimes i would go out
with my roommates
and we would go at like 5 00 p.m because
like that's the only time we can go
um because they like closed early or
whatever like on the weekends
um but yeah it's just too crowded
there's not a lot of space so that's why
i like going at night
there's like nobody there yeah i
remember i
used to go to the gym you had to bring
the barbells with you and we'd get in my
buddy's car and he'd have probably about
360 pounds of barbells in his car
and then the bottom of his car actually
ended up rotting out
because of the weight and also because
of rust he had some rust issues uh
with the vehicle but anyway man what
else is going on uh
not too much really you know just kind
of adapting and went over there to cedar
rapids and
now that if you guys aren't familiar
cedar rapids has been devastated by
something called a directo
and that is a mexican land hurricane
and the real the crazy part is is that
you know for all of the yard and outdoor
kind of outdoor finessing
that a lot of latino and specifically
mexican
people do it's crazy that then a mexican
storm would come
and just ruin
really a lot of the efforts and hard
work
i mean you know you you we we rode
across town before the storm and
uh and or before the show and they had
i mean you'd see a you know a tree
everywhere
everybody had an extra tree in their
yard but it wasn't theirs
it had come from somewhere else
displaced trees
you had somebody you know you'd have a
woodpecker just flying or didn't know
what what to do
you had woodpeckers just kind of like oh
you know have their wings up in there
like that
don't know what's going on because trees
have been just i mean misplaced
displaced m.i.a i
bought a carton of milk on the side
there was a picture of a tree on it
people hadn't seen it you know it just
just a lot going on over there and it
just really devastated a lot of the town
a lot of the city
so um
oh sorry
that's my alarm i set
um so that was interesting man but then
we got out there man and we put it
together out at the amphitheater
i mean and they had it set up beautiful
you know this is an amphitheater
and an amphitheater basically is i mean
this
it was just i mean right on the river
the rivers right there and
he probably had maybe 1100 people came
out and just a real
i mean it was just a good time it was a
perfect night for it and
you know it just felt good people to get
out people had driven in
you know they i met a mexican kid
actually who
from georgie driven in and he had a
southern exit
a southern accent like a red mexican or
something they call them you know
um and i'd never seen it before and i
kept making him talk and we even tickled
him a little
to hear him giggle you know in kind of
like a pseudo kind of
you know kind of uh georgia spanish kind
of
you know you don't see it you don't see
a lot of that
you see a lot of cross-racial stuff
going on with you amongst your friends
you guys have any you have any
you know a black friend that sounds
swedish or a you know a southern kid
that has like a mexican accent do you
you guys seen a lot of that rally not
that extreme but i have friends
um or i have seen people that are
um that are either like for example
they're asian but they have british
accents
oh yeah um i i see that all the time
actually trickery where do you see that
at
what do you mean like where do you see
it are you in part of a club or a group
is this a meet up
yeah i mean i i see it like i sometimes
hear people like when i'm walking down
broadway um and i just look over and
it's
an asian dude and he's just you know
talking
british i was like do you try do you
believe him
yeah yeah because like he's he's not um
he's not like joking around he's just
talking to his friends and like i don't
know one point he was talking about
his family or something so i was like
okay that's like his voice
um same thing with the guy that i watch
on youtube named kai
kai w um that's his user um
that's his uh channel name and he does
all these tech reviews a black guy
no he he's asian okay but i didn't know
he was asian um
like because there's black asian now
you'll see dark asian out there
oh right yeah i would see that it's
crazy i mean it's just you can't even
if you want to be racist still it's hard
right
you gotta have i mean you gotta almost
do you gotta
you gotta read up on stuff exactly you
can't even be
you know when i was young at least you
could just be racist you know it was
easy it was organized it was
you know boom boom boom no no no you
know
right but then now it's like yeah you
got you know
you got the vietnam english you know you
don't know what this guy's gonna do
right you know what i'm saying he's
blowing you know he's playing a flute
and they got the basket with a snake and
the snake is named winston churchill
like you just don't know everything's
mixed up
you know you got the the japanese
and you know you got a guy who's swedish
in japan and japanese
you know you got a guy from um
alabama you know who's also 100
german and this guy's alabama it just
doesn't end it just
it's getting the waters are getting
muddied
right you know i mean you can't even do
a hate crime anymore really
unless you have i mean you got to have
you almost have to have the ancestry 23
paperwork you got to have
you got to call somebody grandparents
you got to just get so much confirmation
it's not even worth the gas money you're
going to spend to drive across town
and burn down somebody's front porch or
whatever
it's just different times man we had a
lot of nice calls that came in though
man let me hit this hotline real quick
985-664-9503
is a hotline and um just people calling
in and just sharing a lot of different
thoughts
as we've migrated into this new
territory over here
in uh in the central east gang yeah what
up
dude uh i just wanted to say
i respect you a lot um
i i know how it is to relocate
and put a lot on the line
just because of an idea and uh
that's how you get anything done that
all starts with an idea and i know it's
probably really uncomfortable right now
being out of your comfort zone and and
being
new to nashville but i just want to let
you know that you
are on the forefront of starting
something really cool
outside of los angeles uh and
well thanks man i appreciate it you know
it's uh
you know i definitely had a week uh
where i was real
real scared actually like what am i
doing um
and that was actually last week you know
uh just what am i doing
um and i realized part of what was i
wasn't really
making as much uh effort
you know not only do i need to go
somewhere
not only do i have to try to get work
going but then also
i need i need to be active you know i
need to actively be trying to bring joy
into my life each day
um and so that's one thing that you know
i got back from cedar rapids
uh yesterday and that's one thing i've
been trying to do since i ha since i've
gotten back and it's just one of my
goals now it's like well how do i
you know how do i really i want to be
able to say i gave
um that i've give sorry if i'm
i'm doing some belches because i've had
a uh zero calorie soda
but um i want to be able to say i've
given this my
uh my best foot forward
you know that's what i want to be able
to say and so you know i got in last
night i was feeling kind of a little bit
bummed out i said you know what i'm
gonna make myself a spaghetti dinner
you know do this grill up you know boil
the noodles and then grill them
i do grilled spaghetti that's how i do
it a lot of people do this old-fashioned
just straight up wet [ __ ] dude
effy is all son i'm grilling the spag
dawg
that's how i do it i i knew you know i
get the need was good then i grill them
up
hit them with the meat sauce
and uh so i made myself some spaghettis
did some running
did some yoga after
and now i'm just batting and then just
decided you know what i'm gonna go to
bed at a decent hour
um and i read i did a little bit of
reading i'm just
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna try to like
actually like say hey man do some things
to make to take
care of yourself
you know i think that will help making
make being in a new place easier no
matter where it is
and i read a book too i'm reading it
actually it's not fully read
but this book is partially read by me so
far
in a book by mike lindell you heard of
this fellow rally mal
i have not you read a lot sometimes it
depends
it depends what i read sound like you
don't read that much but i'll tell you
right now about this book
this book by mike lindell is my pillow
you ever heard of my pillows
the the tv commercial my pillows yeah
yeah
so the man was doing crap the man was a
crack addict
for at least 190 pages of the book he's
smoking crack he can almost smell the
crack
it would almost be cool if they had put
a scratch and sniff on the page where he
could smell a crack a little
because i've never smoked crack to be
honest with you but i always wish that i
had
um but anyway
throughout the book he's smoking crack
and he's doing this and that and he's
struggling
and um man it's a fascinating story
the story is fascinating i mean people i
know sometimes on twitter give the guy a
hard time you know
he's a pretty devout republican and he's
um
uh well i i don't know what else he is i
mean he i think he's a
vikings fan but
the man was smoking crack and then made
one of the most successful pillows of
all time
you know name another can you name
another pillar riley
um yeah the uh
what do you call it um i can't
give it that you can't think of it
because you can't think of it dude
and that's why the uh therapy
therapeutic um
no no nope that's a mattress you're
you're talking tempo yeah you're right
yep pillow is just for your head
mattresses for your body
right and so what i'm telling you about
is this man was smoking crack and then
he made
one of the most successful pillows of
all time
and that doesn't happen on accident
that doesn't happen on accident if
you're smoking crack for
20 30 40 years
the odds of you making one of the most
successful
pillows of all time
is very small
and so what i'm saying is man and i
appreciate the call
and what i'm saying is just like yeah
it's hard to you know sometimes you got
to take that chance
but not only that you got to put your
best foot forward
and so i feel like we're trying
something new out here um
but at the same time we're also trying
to put our best foot forward
but thank you for that call man for the
good for the good fortune
uh i'm fortunate to have people that
just care how i'm doing
you know a lot of calls came into the
hotline this week of just people just
hey man how's it going over there what's
going on
you know people do offering suggestions
and things like that
i gotta ask you are you thinking about
home
warranty coverage well with an american
shield plan you're prepared when stuff
breaks down
in your home if something breaks in your
home
do you have any clue what to do right
now raleigh mao
all right so what uh what i'm talking
about
is the not so easy to fix sometimes
pretty expensive stuff like your
refrigerator heating
and air conditioning plumbing and
electrical
and believe me when it happens not if
you're really going to be glad you have
a plan in place
to see what american home shield covers
and save fifty dollars off any plan go
to
ahs.com
t-h-e-o be sure with the shield
policy genius guys are you a genius
nope well that really answers it doesn't
it
because policy genius saves their home
and auto customers an average of
1 127 a year
by shopping top rated insurers in one
place
yep they do it if you're thinking one
thousand one hundred twenty seven
dollars is a strange amount it is
but in crunching the numbers which is
one of the things policy
genius does best their marketplace
figured out that's exactly how much they
save each
customer all you have to do is head to
policygenius.com and answer a few quick
questions
about yourself about your property about
your goods
after that policy genius does all the
work
they do it they'll compare your existing
policy with
all the policies that are out there
they're checking the marketplace you
don't have to
if policy genius finds a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll get you switched for free
they have a five-star rating plus over
1600 reviews on
trustpilot and google so if you're a
homeowner
head to policygenius.com right now to
get started
they've saved their home and auto
insurance customers an average of one
thousand one hundred and twenty seven
dollars a year
that's a specific number but they are
very
specific that's right go to
policygenius.com right now to get
started
all right let's take this call right
here what's up theo
this is luke calling from the southern
indiana louisville area
luke
i think you're gonna like living along
the i-65
you know you can go all the way up to
chicago go down to the beach
uh but well i appreciate you saying that
also i would like to say anybody who
i love you luke but also anybody who
references you're gonna love living
along a certain
interstate is 95 out of 97 times
a serial killer
i think that's safe to say
i think that's safe to say you know
anybody that's been serial killed riley
i don't no well
live a little brother i have two friends
who's have uh family members have been
victims of serial killers or sks they
call them let's hear more luke
but you know there's a lot of people
calling in about
getting sober and then uh just having a
void there
and i think riley would agree with me
that that void could be filled
in a church community nashville is full
of
a bunch of really great churches i've
been down there and a few churches
and uh you know even i know you've been
to church before and even if you're not
religious you know i think there's a lot
of
good people there and amen brother i
appreciate that suggestion
and there's a ton of churches here i've
made a bunch of u-turns usually in
church parking lots
because they're empty a lot of times and
you can and they're everywhere
so especially here out here in the
central east you'll see that sort of
deal
you'll you know a u-turn is popularly
done
in a church parking lot which isn't bad
either because you kind of zip through
you know
you get in there get a little you know
get that quick head of the lord in your
brain and then you're back out
on your route but i appreciate that man
i lo
you know i love churches you know i love
uh
you know i love the camaraderie
when i was growing up my dad used to
take us over there to the presbyterian
church
and he would uh put his business cards
in the damn
uh basket that went around
you know the dollars for god basket he'd
throw his business card in there he
always thought it was they were grab
they were uh
drawing for a free lunch
so he'd throw a couple business cards in
there and he didn't have any business my
dad didn't even have a business
his business card had his name on it and
his phone number
so i mean i don't i guess i guess that's
business i don't know
this was back when you know in these
eight these times if you were even a man
you were
considered doing business
just by the simple fact of being male
you were considered a businessman oh he
does business that fella
look at him the guy with the beard with
the wiener
oh that means business and so i get he
would throw the card in the church in
the money basket
i don't know what he thought but he
never won a lunch or anything like that
but i used to love it you know i used to
love also going to the church and doing
the easter egg hunt
and my brother was fast and he had dark
skin and people would say oh look at
that
look at that little puerto rican fella
getting all eggs
but it was different times man
riley mao i know you have a japanese
roots eggs are sacred in japanese don't
you guys have faberge eggs and
you know a lot of times a certain i'll
see a designed egg
um i honestly i don't even know what
that is i've never seen one
um yeah
wow i have no idea what you're talking
about wow i'm sorry
that's all right man why know your
history that's the thing about kids now
they don't need to know their history
who cares how did you get here i don't
know space shuttle
who's your dad elon musk every it
doesn't matter
every kid thinks it was born in a tesla
you know their baby crib is tesla baby
they don't even know
they power down at 2 a.m
they don't need lunch are these people
human anymore
that's my big question sorry to put that
on you raleigh but
no totally fine but you got to know that
number one
you know when i was young a lot of times
we would learn about different cultures
in school
you know and not that often but every
now and then they have us make a faberge
egg
and it's a special type of asian egg
where they draw the
history of asia on the outside of it so
you'll see a fellow on a cruise
you don't want to ship or on a you know
you'll see somebody doing a
you know hitting somebody with a sword
or a
you know somebody at a temple you know
just history
and they put it on the egg
let's take another call that came in
here thanks for the good wishes though
man and i do think uh
you know there's a lot to be found at
church actually and actually riley you
might know do you have a
you know is there a special memory you
have from church
as a child you know man i've got many
um like i said in one of the previous
episodes my
um my home church is eastside eastside
christian church and
okay it's a big mega church and like our
worship is just amazing our christmas
services are super spectacular they're
so unique
do you have real animals in them no
unfortunately not
um we're not one of those kind of
churches yet at least
i don't know if they have i don't know
if they ever will but i don't think they
will
yeah i've been to one i bought tickets
to the one out there in california had
real animals at it
dang real animals real elephant
real giraffe baby coming right down the
aisle wow yeah pretty crazy yeah they
had a um
they had a camel actually they defecated
on the stage and then it got sick and
they had to have a
they had to suspend one of the services
but um anyway
tell me more about what you were saying
yeah and uh what's a specific memory
something you enjoyed
um i would say definitely the all the
christmas services
because they're not just our normal
christmas or our normal services or
normal any christmas services that you
see anywhere else like we've got snow
coming from the ceiling
we've got like we go all out but there's
always this one tradition where
um at the end we always sing silent
night together
three times oh three time in a row three
times in a row
yep you can't forget it exactly
see when i was young they sing it one
time and you knew it
and that's the difference now you gotta
sing silent night three times for the
youngsters
that's a just you if you wanted to have
it
if you want to have a real sentimental
imprint you
you just got to hit them hard
you gotta hit them hard y'all do the egg
hunts over there
for easter yeah um
no well are you talking about church or
like just in general church
uh church no okay well
could be a good church could not be a
good church i'm not saying anything
about eastside man
you know they sound like it sounds like
a great outfit but it you know
hide an egg
hide an egg if you want to keep the kids
involved that's what that that was a
motto by our church but
um all right let's hear one more call
that came in man
hey theo this is ben smith at arkansas
ben smith thank you for calling brother
i appreciate it man and
arkansas is a good place a lot of geodes
up there in geodes
or g odds i'm not even sure how you
pronounce that
g odds giad
homeward we just poured the morning
coffee
it's uh tuesday morning about to head
into work
have some quiet time first man i just
wanted to say uh
congrats on moving to uh the central
part of the country it's a good place
uh i'm excited for you to experience
fall in tennessee man
we're almost there to get cool weather
all the leaves are gonna change colors
everybody's favorite time of year you
know
hey man i just wanted to say also uh
you know moving to a new spot is hard
i've moved around a bunch
um just some weird places i got to live
in
central america for a while i lived out
in arizona uh
well i'm gonna jump out on a limb here
man but if you're living in central
america and arizona
it sounds like you're trying to be
mexican or spanish
or latino
so i don't want to check in uh you know
you know i don't want to body check you
up in a coat of arms but
you know you might want to look at your
roots and make sure what's going on is
what's going on
because it sounds like you might be
maybe you're adopted
you know i don't just get called to a
certain area
you know if i find myself hanging out in
cameroon or
nigeria after a while i'm gonna start
wondering you know who my real father is
brother
onward moved around a little bit and
man you know it's it it's hard being
somewhere for a while at first you know
it uh it takes a while to get into that
rhythm
so um hang in there dude and and uh
know that this is like probably the uh
the hardest part of moving to new places
is at the time you're in right now so
well thanks man it's nice you to say
that
yeah yeah i think some of it is you know
i find myself at night i want to
i want that's when i get because you
have more free time here
you know in los angeles you know a lot
of your time is spent in traffic
or you know or just crying in your car
or
um you know there's just a lot of
separation between things there's no
parking when you get somewhere so you
have to park a block away and
you know it's just there's a lot of
barriers
between you and comfort
and i'm not judging the place i'm not
saying that look man
when i went home last week for three
days i went to the beach and i loved it
i mean i loved every second of it
you know i don't know if i've ever felt
closer to god in my life than just
laying out there
after having just got out the water and
just laying out in the sun out there
you know just laying face down in the
sand you know
i mean i was at peace you know some big
lady even thought it was a deceased body
came up and pushed my body
thought i was deceased so i don't know
how many closer to god you can get than
being than people thinking you're
deceased you know
i mean hell my brother would have hit a
damn mint under my body
but um but i do notice you have more
time
in a place uh in a place like nashville
you have more time
it's just easier to get around things
are quicker and faster
and you get more time so
um so i find myself around eight to
eight at night i'm like ah
what do i do
you know i have a couple friends here
through a a program and so they don't
you know
they ain't doing nothing they trying not
to masturbate or trying not to drink you
know
so we're not all like oh let's go meet
up at this joint
so just kind of like trying to find
things to do
so that's kind of the toughest moments
you know my toughest thing was
last week i was struggling with
masturbation really past two weeks i
also tried testosterone replacement
i tried testosterone replacement and uh
i mean it just makes you just i mean it
just
it just gives you so much virility
i mean it'll make your penis reach for a
damn deck of cards i mean it just
is so it just i mean it just brings your
body to life
and so suddenly you're more
you know you'll just be doing nothing
and your penis will jump into your own
hand it's just more
it's not that good so i don't think i'm
gonna take it anymore
um it makes your hair thinner
you know i don't i didn't like that i
find extra hair sitting around and i
need my hair
you know i i definitely like having hair
so that's really strange um
and what else about it
oh uh you also they have it's in it's
injection based
it's injection based you know and um
i used to do steroids when i was young
uh
you know we used to shoot you know a lot
of people know me and my
buddy um billy conforto
r.i.p and he died and he was one of the
premier bus boys in america also
probably one of the top
i would say 40 gay prize fighters
or gay boxers fist fighters
in i would say in the 1990s
in america and uh maybe in the world i
would say in the world
top 40 homoerotic fist fighters
in i would say in first world countries
and uh
i don't know second world you get into a
second world country bro you get down
there in
ecuador brah and a gay dude will beat
the hell out of you bro it's nothing
that's casual that's dancing
that's dancing for them um
but what was i talking about
oh man i don't even know dude
oh so yeah you also have to take this
other
drug with it they have a drug also that
um
because if you take testosterone it will
it makes your gonads they call them
gonads on the internet but really it's
your nuts
and it makes them smaller and so you
take another
drug that makes your basically makes
your gonads
regular size it's kind of like a fluffer
it's like uh you ever put a little air
in your bike tire a little
it's like that
just like that man but um
but anyway i'm just real i just don't
think it's for me so
i uh so i'm gonna quit taking it
you know i've tried it out it's been
about a month maybe
six weeks
and i just don't i think the hair i
don't want to lose my hair
and
i i don't know i don't know if i notice
a lot of other benefits and stuff from
it really
um
[Music]
so and then
if you take the the the secondary drug
that they have
if whenever you take that it makes your
kind of makes your nuts feel like
somebody hid something in them
it makes kind of it makes your nuts feel
like somebody just blew all their breath
like somebody just
like blew one mouth full of breath right
into them
it's like you got this kind of you know
it's like you got this uh
um it's like a fl it's just like
somebody
just puffed your nuts up a little so i
don't like that feeling it's like you're
hot it's like somebody hit a easter egg
right in your
crotch or something in your nuts
and that makes me feel uncomfortable i
don't like that feeling it just feels
fake
so anyway so that's my experience with
it
you know when it's not um and you get it
there's different ways you can get the
testosterone replacement it's for sale
everywhere now and
so i wanted to try it out uh
and and the injection part is a little
weird
like i don't trip out on it that much
because i did it when i was young
you know to body build so
it's just a low dose but it does make me
feel you know comfortable i feel like um
and just the upkeep of it and stuff i
just don't feel like it's for me
that's kind of the conclusion that i've
come to so
um but yeah man i think if i find a good
church i think that
that that that's a good idea you know
so i appreciate that man um
what else was i talking about you ever
done any injectable drugs riley now
i mean unless it's for surgery um the uh
what do you call it the thing that makes
you go to sleep for surgery
other than that no anesthesia you mean
yeah that
okay that's the thing but you never just
you know
you and your buddy you know never pulled
off the interstate and done steroids or
anything like that
nope unfortunately not well
no i'm not uh i'm not uh i'm not one of
those guys i'm like
you know the calm innocent kind
yeah i don't i don't do any of those
drugs i don't do any of those like
injections or whatever
um i mean you know me i'm yeah i don't
know you
but i'm learning that yeah that is not
your
vice right what would you say would you
feel like is a vice
if people say oh riley mouse say it's
your funeral okay we're at your funeral
people like oh raleigh man man he's a
great guy
you know he uh
he was an eagle scout he was a christian
you know he
was a um
he was a uh karate belt he had a karate
belt
he skipped lunch sometimes he worked so
hard and what would they say but also
one of his vices was he did this what
would it be you think
um and i don't know well i guess people
would say
that i'm more the
i'm more the quiet kind of guy until you
really get to know me
and then i'm just like obnoxious like
you will
you will regret wanting to get to know
me because i'm like so obnoxious towards
them and i like i like talking a lot
um other than that um wow yeah i'm i'm a
pretty quiet dude other than that um
all right man that's something uh
people called actually we had a couple
calls that came in here
let me see what this fella said right
here
yo this is wide out nebraska
what's up wyatt from nebraska man thank
you for calling brother and thank you
for listening to this uh
this um podcast i want to give you a
little riley review
uh to be honest i was i didn't think it
was gonna work out very well this kid
is 22 seems to be a little young to be
on a platform so big
does he deserve it is he a relative
i i didn't know what was going on
there's some dead air
it's hard to pull answers out of them
it's really awkward uh it's not going to
give him a second chance of listening to
your show right now the second episode
with him on there
and it's almost brilliant to have that
type of
feeling in the air like it's just
awkward it's almost like part of the act
even though it might not meant to be
it's it's it's funny as hell
and then your boy was telling me that he
is
asian and a black belt that's a win-win
i'm now on
but that's easy also let's don't act
like that's not
y'all sport be honest right
kind of back on his side i'm on the
fence i don't know
but uh you're gonna need someone smart
to do all those editing anyway
especially one that doesn't get out of
that pocket
you know so there you go that guy had
some thoughts on you raleigh
and i'm not playing those two as any
judgment you know
um i just wanted to let you know that
people uh there was a call
let me see was there an i felt like
there was another call but
i do not see it in here um
so have you felt did you have you felt
uh
from being on the podcast i love being
on the podcast you do yeah
it's a lot of fun okay man well good
man you know we just want you to you
know uh feel comfortable here and
um you know i mean just like life it's
always like you know we kind of talked
about it's like a learner you know it's
just we learn as we go we don't really
know what it's going to be like you know
right so but i'm glad you came back
today man
thanks for having me back yeah you bet
man if you're an e-commerce seller
are you ready to meet the demands of a
record-breaking online shopping
season shipstation helps online sellers
get orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs
and keep customers happy no matter where
you're selling amazon etsy
or your own website that's right
ship station brings all your orders into
one
simple interface making them really easy
to manage even from your cell phone
that's right if you're selling something
you know i got friends that sell sell
sell
sell stuff you know i got friends that
run the beat pure apiary
down there in louisiana and they sell
honey and honey goods
and i should tell them hey use ship
station
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of massive online shopping
season free 60 days when you use offer
code theo
that's shipstation.com make ship
happen all right we got a call came in
from a fella right here who probably
has some problem let's hear it hey theo
this is dennis
calling out at callahan florida big
dentist out there in callahan
big dentist let's hear it and i was at
work
and i just got stung by a bee in the
neck
and i'm [ __ ] livid but you know i
just
wanna express that get that off my chest
man i'm really i'm really pissed
okay well look man i'm sorry to hear
that man i know that it's
you know a b don't know nothing a b
is like a blind guy with a damn hatchet
you know he don't know you from adam bro
you know he'll sting his [ __ ]
stepmother if you give him half a dollar
like a b don't give a damn
if you crack open a bee there ain't a
damn in that thing
we had a fella actually when i was
growing up we used to go to summer camp
i think it was summer camp i don't know
they didn't do anything really
they kept us in a damn pavilion out at
the park and it was hot as could be
and everybody had kool-aid mustaches and
everybody had to bring their own lunch
and your lunch your kool-aid would spill
in your lunch thing and it would get all
wet and you had to eat it anyway
so if you haven't had a raspberry
kool-aid grilled cheese sandwich in
we might not know each other but one
thing uh
we had they had a fella out there was a
groundskeeper and a groundskeeper
basically somebody that's homeless but
also
you know it you know kind of hangs out
in one specific area
and this fella b.i they call him he
would uh he had a glass
eye or some type of textile eye
you know this fella had something happen
you know i'm saying he lost one of them
bad
sight balls and somebody you know hooked
him up with that replica
and he would get bees there were bees
everywhere
bees on every there was bees on
everything bees on every trash can had a
thousand bees on it
and he would take a beat and he would
sting right into his own eye with it
and it would freak the kids out because
we never seen it
and then here you go he's doing it
and he would just get a bee and just
sting and the kids if it was a new kid
or somebody that was coming to camp for
a week
because it was ymca summer camp
so every week is when you get a new kid
in
and sometime it you know some fella or
some little lady come in there
sometime they get the little squirrely
kid with the real pale skin
a couple freckles kind of some dark
freckles curly hair
creeping everybody out
you know real kind of vein you know like
real veiny eyes just
he always had that one little fella
creeping people
and my friend daniel actually this
little fellow growing up bus we had this
miscreant fellow
riley man named daniel and he would do
cigarettes man or do
you know he he's uh he um
super glued his own mouth closed once
and it just whole neighborhood was
furious man
and when they finally got it open he
laughed at everybody
dang
so we had people like that you know we
had real miscreants dude
um we had a fella drank a little bit of
ethanol
this kid named todd man and he looked
like he really looked like [ __ ] but he
looked like [ __ ] before he drank it
so
but uh anyway what was i talking about
man
todd no no no before that man
daniel no before that uh
oh bees baby
mother nature's freaking pitchforkers
dog
uh and this fellow would just sting his
own eye with him just take him and just
sting right into his own eye because he
had a
not a homemade eye but semi homemade you
know to step
up from homemade like maybe they'd made
it in homeek
so he had that you know he had that home
back eye and he would just and if you
didn't know the
new kids didn't know so every time after
lunch he'd get a kid over there and
get his get a live b and sting his own
eye with it
geez you have any unique individuals or
role models like that growing up riley
oh man as far as the like
i don't think i can go that far as like
be singing in
your own eye um other than that no i
mean i've had
like you know there's like those special
kids that are like you know in special
ed and
you know i have a few friends in that
too i have a few um blind friends that
are like super good at
you know audio at audio engineering at
my school
um it's crazy listeners huh big
listeners
oh yeah yeah they're like the best
students there we had a guy like that
too
they call him the big listener and he
was blind or something was wrong with
him he said he couldn't see
and people believed him right and he
could hear
he was that freaking that's that
listener
you know he was just damn christopher
columbus on the listenership man he was
just
and we had a blind kid that could play
kickball real well
and he could hear the ball rolling fill
it on the ground
and kick it just the damn willie nelson
of kickball just the real
i mean this guy was just
just damn kirby puckett man this fella
old fat leg he had a fat leg on him too
a lot of blind people are fat in the
legs
what else we got here man
we got a young fella right here hit a h
hit the hotline man
uh let's hear it here we go
hey theo this is will i called about a
year ago
my daughter eliana was born oh man
congratulations on that one year old you
got now man
that's a beautiful treat man my buddy
just had a kid
about maybe nine weeks ago or something
and he sent me a picture of it and it
looked like a damn little ghost
little scared little fella but still
beautiful man amen let's hear it
appreciate that by the way let me on the
show
i just wanted to kind of ask your
thoughts about
the crystal leah situation because i
heard you and bobby talking about that
last week and i was thinking to myself
if one of my buddies got some deep stuff
some trouble and he said like hey
i didn't do that that wasn't me
like i'd want to back obviously
that the crystalia situation is pretty
uh deep deeper than that
um but i mean you even said like
like people were mad about him talking
to a 22 year old
so like maybe it's not as bad as the
cracked up to be i don't know much about
it
to be honest that's not the base facts
so i don't know man do you ever feel bad
about
not backing him like
well i appreciate your question man um i
mean there's
there's you know and yeah me and bobby
were talking about this the other day on
uh
on the episode and i think
i i i back chris you know like i check
in with him
you know i probably should check in with
him again um
you know chris doesn't communicate a ton
with me
we never have communicated like a great
deal like
our friendship you know we haven't had
like a deep deep friendship
um i think he's one of the funniest guys
that i know
i don't so i don't know the extent of
everything that's going on either
you know i don't know the extent do i
believe everything that's
that do i believe that the articles that
people have written like a lot of it
seems like hit pieces to me
you know but also i don't know
everything about it
you know i i feel like um
it's really tough you know because
people do everything now for click bait
it's really tough um
but i do know that i you know
that it's tough for a lot of his friends
and a lot of his associates
and co-workers to know what to say or do
because he hasn't really said much
so i think in a weird way we're all kind
of waiting
not waiting to hear from him i mean and
he did say his piece there was an
article he
that he had or that was about like his
side of the story and his thoughts on it
and
um you know i don't know i don't know if
there's like legal stuff that he's
facing i don't know
and some of it is interesting because
it's like it's not my
you know like um it's not my
responsibility to
or it's not it's none of my business to
bother him to bother him about any of
that
you know i check in and say you know you
know how are you doing
you know thinking of you um
i don't look at i mean the media often
looks at people as one-dimensional
oh they're just this or that's how it
seems a lot of times
um but i mean i support you know i
support my friends as much as i
you know i love him
you know i want him to be able to work
um i'm grateful that he has a family
right now that he has a wife and kid
kitten he has people that are close to
him to support him
and people to keep him hopeful and
excited
um
you know i don't know i don't know what
a lot of his behaviors were
like really no you know i don't know
i don't go you know i i'm
so it's like
you know yeah you i have their back i
have my friends back
i mean a lot of everything we do you you
don't see it on podcasts you don't
always hear about it
um there's also a lot of like a lot of
guys are afraid and a lot of people are
afraid i think just of
you know of a lot of just you know are
they going to be written an article
about next even if
some of the stuff it doesn't even have
any validity
um you know it's scary
it makes me feel uncomfortable it makes
me feel scared to even talk about like i
have to watch my words
um
[Music]
because there's people out there that
want to take people's livelihood away
but then also if people did something
that is illegal
then i feel like that they should be
held accountable for it
but also i don't feel like people that
if they did something illegal that that
damns them as a someone that i could
should care about
or that there's not more to them as a
person
i mean dude we're all like just messed
up creatures trying to freaking
balance right between the sand and and
the and
the water so
you know it's tricky out there
it's tricky out there it's tricky in
here tricky inside of ourselves man it's
tricky everywhere
but when people say you didn't back him
what is backing someone look like i mean
i've let him know that i love him i've
let him know that
you know i'm here for him i've let him
know that if he feels like he has an
issue or
with anything that he's welcome to you
know i go to different meetings for all
types of stuff so
he's welcome to come with me anytime he
wants to or
but i appreciate the reminder may you
know maybe i should check in with him
again and just you know remind him
that people think about him you know
that people care about him you know i
texted callum the other day and told him
you know
to keep his head up
um just as i would text any of my
friends or communicate any with any of
my friends who if something bad happened
to them
you know just as i'm sure like the
accusers
are or the victims of of the alleged
incidents or their friends are
supporting them
you know it's i don't know
i'm just human man i i don't know
but um
anyway man let's get another call or two
that came in man i want to thank
everybody that came out about the uh
cedar rapid
you know i want to thank everybody that
came out for the cedar rapids show
and uh let's get those calls right now
hey d.o it's boy daniel at northeast
arkansas
what's up big daniel out of northeast
you ever been there raleigh i've not
well actually what is northeast arkansas
like what cities
man let's hear more
uh not i don't i'm not the hot host
hitter but
yeah uh man just let you know be driving
up there
saturday come see in cedar rapids as
long as my wife doesn't kill me
while we drive for seven hours but uh
man i'm just gonna let you know
along with helping people dealing with
uh addictions and everything
you also help us who only had a mother
growing up
and uh and wasn't really close to her
a while back let's see here you said how
your mom had to be your disciplinary
figure and your comfort person
man that just that comment opened up a
slew of emotions i didn't even know i
had
just from realizing that and
anyway i was able to put my relationship
back together with my mom
you know we're a lot stronger now so
thanks man thanks for the nice call man
uh i hope you guys enjoyed the show
yeah seven hours with your wife in a car
that's really
i mean that should be a damn game show i
feel like
that should be uh that should be a
really
a dirty game show but um
yeah man well i appreciate you saying
that man uh you know my mother actually
went to it's
almost just funny and full circle my
mother went to college over there in um
cedar rapids and um
and she met her first husband over there
over there
and uh but
yeah it's funny man i you know
it's interesting when a kid you know
when you just have the single parent
when you just have the mom
[Music]
and i didn't realize until i was older i
just looked at my mind it's like
you start to i think
not having a dad around you in a weird
way you hold that against your mother
i mean you would you just hold it
against whoever's the remaining parent
so i think if it's
if you just have a dad or i did
i don't know if people do
but then suddenly you know yeah your
mother has two roles and
and i don't even know if our moms
realize it at the time
that suddenly they're the mother and the
father and
and it's just so much man there's so
much that goes into all of it
but yeah i was holding probably i was
probably always been i probably held i
was holding
i was holding or maybe still hold the
things against my mother
that maybe were a father's
responsibility
and that's why sometimes i get hung up
on like yeah i like the two-parent
system man it's
you know it just
because i know what it feels like not to
have it that's why
some people you know they get all
political about it well you don't like
you
you don't think two women can raise a
care two men
i don't know about all of that or i can
just you know
get my eggs fertilized at the chemical
plant or whatever and i can have a
family
yeah i think all those things are great
things and it's okay but
you know i just the only thing i know is
that
when you're when you don't have that you
there's just parties sometimes this is
just doesn't develop or something
i don't know man uh
and sometimes it's easier for me to
think about these things and sometimes
it's
it's harder for me to think about them
and feel them
because thinking about stuff doesn't get
me anywhere man i really have to feel it
like i have to like
try and take myself back to the place of
when i was a kid and what did it feel
like you know
and and how
you know like and think of myself and
looking at my mother and like did i look
at did i think of her as
you know i have to try and navigate
those feelings
and really see where i land sometimes
but
um
but yeah man life is it's just man
there's so many
there's so much going on and i'm not
trying to be a downer or anything man i
appreciate the nice words and
you know and then in the end of it all
it's like
what am i i can't still what am i still
gonna hold grudges from
you know it just doesn't do me any good
so as much as in some places me i feel
empty
if i pin
my emptiness on somebody else as their
fault
then it's just really just
it's just creating it just create it's
letting that emptiness still create more
negativity
and as much as it hurts to have to just
deal with it myself and to patch it up
sometimes it's just like that's the only
real solution
because man yeah sometimes i still want
to blame i get you know i just want to
blame and
but usually those feelings go away
pretty quick
uh are those moments where i feel that
way but
anyway man thanks for bringing that
up you know uh
and yeah i hope your wife didn't kill
you and i hope you guys had a good time
at the show
let's take one more call here here we go
hi theo my name is kristen and i just
got home
from your show in cedar rapids me and
two of my family members drove out there
from chicago
and i just wanted to thank you for the
laughs it was a really good night
we had a family member passed away
earlier this month and
it was nice to just get out there and
take a break from reality so
just wanted to thank you and we love you
and gang gang
thank you so much gang mama
thank you thank you for that nice
message i'm glad you guys made the trip
you know that's a three hour trip right
there or something
two hour and you made it in yeah man we
put a lot of laughter up into the sky
out there
that's one nice thing about being
outdoors that laughter can hit the air
baby
that's air bound that's free that's no
walls caging up the vibes
and we let it hit the air son
i mean we were using profanity they
could hear three buildings down they
could hear it a block and a half away
and we lit it up
so i'm sorry to hear about that i'm
sorry to hear that you guys lost
somebody that you loved
but it's powerful to hear that you guys
you know
took their spirit with you and put and
took it out and did something nice you
know
i'm glad you know
yeah sometimes i think you know that the
laughter it just hits the air and it
goes right on up to heaven man
and that's all they hear up there that's
the only thing they're allowed to hear
up in heaven is just laughter so that's
the only thing they can really hear
are good sounds you know
you know they don't let bad sounds in
there only good sounds what's a good
sound you think riley mal
i mean good sounds as in
like just anything in general like a
good sound yeah
um i mean laughter is a good sound um
i don't know rocket flying into space is
a good sound an elephant
i like elephants elephants are a good
sound
what what do you think is a good sound
laughter i think and uh
what else man sometimes a little sexual
activity but i won't listen long if i
hear it if the neighbors are doing it
i'll listen for like
like two or three seconds but i ain't
listening
i'll bur like listen a little and then
pretend like i i'll be like oh well
what is that sound but then uh once i he
definitely know if it's sexual
interaction i back off
you know so
i don't listen a lot of that man
but um
what else that's it
thank you for the call you know i love
you
and um and i hope you guys had a good
time out there
i really do that's important
that's important that's all there is man
that's all there is
is moving on getting in the car going on
getting on the train getting on the bike
getting on the skateboard getting back
on the horse
and keeping it moving
that's all there is man i feel like
we've been through a lot and
um
you know i've just been thinking about
uh
well i haven't really been thinking
about anything actually
i got to ice my ribs down a little
you ever had rib damage raleigh now i've
not
and i don't want to
there you go folks the hot take
from raleigh now baby let's get into
this the same way that we came in
uh this is north mississippi all-stars
and you talk about not giving up this
band has been at it
uh forever and i mean
um they are just so beloved and uh this
is off their album
up and rolling and this is drunk
[Music]
outdoors
outdoors little dirty dance floors
let's go get drunk outdoors
[Music]
outdoors
you guys be good to yourselves man and
i'm gonna try doing the same thing to
[Music]
myself
you